أسقطت سفينة تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية 14 طائرة بدون طيار
انطلقت من المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الحوثيون في
اليمن، وهذا وفقًا
للقيادة المركزية الأمريكية، وهذا هو الأحدث في سلسلة
من الهجمات التي نفذها المسلحون الحوثيون على
أهداف أمريكية واضحة وعلى
السفن التجارية في البحر الأحمر وخليج
عدن.  والتي تقول الجماعة إنها ردًا
أو انتقامًا للحرب الإسرائيلية
داخل غزة، فالحوثيون هم
مجموعة مسلحة متحالفة على نطاق واسع مع الثورة الإسلامية،
ويعتقد المسؤولون الأمريكيون أنهم ينتهزون
الفرصة بشكل انتهازي لمحاولة تصوير
أنفسهم في المنطقة وفي الداخل
كمدافعين عن إسرائيل.  لأنهم
ليسوا تحت القيادة والسيطرة المباشرة
من إيران ولكن إيران تقدم لهم
التدريب على الأسلحة وتمويلها. المشكلة
بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة هنا هي أنه في حين أنهم
يشعرون بقلق عميق بشأن تأمين
الشحن في بابوم مان ديب مباشرة
وما بعده، لذلك  الاقتصاد العالمي
لم يتأثر، فهم يريدون أيضًا تجنب
الوضع الذي
يمتص فيه الصراع الإسرائيلي مع حماس إيران والولايات
المتحدة بشكل مباشر. حتى الآن، يعتقد المسؤولون الأمريكيون
أن إيران تقوم بمعايرة
ردها على الغزو الإسرائيلي لغزة
من خلال السماح لمجموعات بالوكالة بالانطلاق
الهجمات على الولايات المتحدة
والأهداف المرتبطة بإسرائيل تصل إلى حد معين
ولكن ليس أبعد من ذلك، ولهذا السبب جزئيًا
رأيت الولايات المتحدة تتصرف بضبط النفس
حتى الآن وتتجنب الرد مباشرة على
هذه الهجمات الحوثية التي يحاولون
منع تصعيد الوضع.  أه
المسؤولون الأمريكيون يعتقدون أيضًا إلى حد كبير أنهم
قادرون على التعامل مع العديد من
هذه الذخائر التي أطلقها الحوثيون، وقد
أسقطوا مرارًا وتكرارًا طائرات بدون طيار في اتجاه واحد،
ولا يُنظر إلى الصواريخ الباليستية الحوثية المحلية على أنها دقيقة بشكل خاص، كما أن
صواريخ كروز أكثر
دقة قليلاً ولكنها ليست كذلك  من الواضح أنهم
يستطيعون فعليًا تسلل سفينة، لذلك في هذه
الحالة من المحتمل أن الحوثيين
كانوا يحاولون استخدام ما يعرف بتكتيك
السرب بإطلاق طائرات بدون طيار متعددة
لمحاولة إرباك الدفاعات الجوية الأمريكية والتغلب عليها
بأعداد كبيرة، ومن الواضح أن هذا
لا يبدو  أن هذا نجح في هذه
الحالة، لذلك أعتقد أن الشيء الذي يجب مراقبته
هنا سيكون عند أي نقطة
تعتبر إدارة بايدن أن هذه
الهجمات المستمرة من الحوثيين
أصبحت خطيرة جدًا على
الشحن الدولي لدرجة أنه لا يمكن الاستمرار في الرد عليها
في هذه المرحلة.  من الواضح أنه تم
الوصول إلى هذه العتبة كاتي بوليس سي
إن إن
واشنطن